you
here we go there we go we'll go with
this again I had a good position against
you the last time we played this well
not this to this exact position okay
we're gonna have a queen trade I'm fine
with that it's throwing a check see what
you do about that
and now what Bishop here I guess I want
to play e5 my bishop needs to get back
here right here Knight d7 Bishop here
okay this is my good Bishop that's being
exchanged not too much I could do about
that though all right let's get rid of
their Bishop if I take I'm inviting the
knight to come back into play so I'll
just hold off and develop okay now just
it's this is still such a tough position
right now actually it's a losing
position oh can you believe that I'm
dropping this pawn em
no I'm not well yeah I probably am let's
try this defense there's this night
check here and a night check here I
guess I don't know hmm
I want to secure my night here so I have
this defended there is gonna be this
night check though I think it's
important to secure his position okay
I'm in check gotta go here to defend g7
when I kick that night out of there and
get my King back here hang on
hmm Knight takes pawn is at the front
let's get my king up this is gonna be a
problem Knight takes here is still a
threat and Knight coming in here is
gonna be a pain I think maybe maybe not
maybe not well actually if I play here
then it is a problem because the knight
comes in and if I play f6 Knight here is
a fork so what am I getting at hmm what
can I do
I could just defend this pawn like rook
b8 I really don't want to move it why do
I don't I want to move it actually wait
a second if I play b5 where's this night
going might not be a bad idea b5 that
way I'm not having to babysit anything
here b5 Knight b7 i can play rook here
let's give it a shot
what am i missing that huh I'm not
afraid of that mouth got some space I
have this square now this is a new hole
now this is what I thought I would be
able to do f6 these Knights are
SuperDuper close to my king but what are
they really doing like okay my rook is
hit see that rook here though easy does
it
yeah I figured you would do just that I
figured this much neither Knight can
move well he can't move without him
dropping takes takes takes get the
Knights back in a super duper active
rook I don't want to allow that you guys
should move this Knight and then drop my
e5 pawn let's not do that
what about Knight here this nights gonna
move though and then this night will be
picked up okay
I think I need to defend my night and I
think I need to do that laterally let's
go here I mean at 39 ah you got nothing
you've got nothing
oh you got nothing maybe I could get two
knights versus a rook position two minor
pieces versus of rook 96 with Knight
here cutting off the circulation here
with the rooks interference move I could
even support it with c5 where is the
tactic though Knight here is there some
tricky tactic got a watch there is this
Knight check but my rook is there to
defend oh that's another thing you know
what I'm never really in a position to
take here because of this Knight fork
so maybe my rook has to actually come
here first just to watch over these
sneaky checks on c8 now you're running
away yes you are you are running away
and I think I might be close to winning
that night let's try this what am I
missing
tell me ah figured you'd have something
I figured this much
mmm night here pawn takes pawn takes
rook takes Knight takes I'm still gonna
go for it threatening this Knight I'm
still threatening the night if rook
takes I'm gonna take with my night on
the night I'm still on the night King
here the rook is cut off here to here I
want my king on g7 oh I gotta make a
move
ah you you sneaky computer what am I
missing
a perpetual that's what it's going
forward perpetual oh I guess I'll take
it ah man that's all I had at that point
I guess it was in an inferior position
at the end of that it's nearly 3:30 a.m.
and I'm playing a computer an impossible
beast here I'm actually happy with
myself with that game believe it or not
because those night Sarge is so tricky
it's all about calculation and
apparently I didn't miss any simple
tactics
you